[Music]
what's your name Laura surname Croft
Laura
your father's gone you could pick up
where he left off
I see so much of him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead I
found something
a tomb called the mother of death if
Trinity succeeds our world is in danger
promise me you will stop I promise I
think I know where my dad went that's
right in the middle of the devil sea
it'll be an adventure death isn't hotter
than adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did
[Music]
what I know about my father now I see
the lightness the recklessness close the
to once and for the fate of humanity is
now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days
the world has gone bloody mad I'll take
two I was quite young there was only
eight I remember my dad's friends
children he had a Playstation I remember
when they played Laura Croft I hadn't
seen a girl in the lead character in a
video game she was extremely fierce and
determined capable and epic adventurer
I've been dreaming since I was a kid be
part of a big action adventure to push
myself and in this film I really kept do
[Music]
all stories very much an origin story
surname Croft in the beginning she's a
regular girl living in East London
here's the part since she's seen her dad
so she goes out an adventure to see if
he's still out there
didn't come here I'm glad that you did
this film is about her becoming the
action here that we know her to be when
it comes to the action Alisha as a beast
you have to see her in this movie man
she's just a winning combination you
know she's been training hard Fight Club
while work water work shootouts chases
it's relentless
I was amazed by what she went through
she gets beaten up all day long bruises
and the hips you kind of just suck up
but the cold that is the tough thing
when you reach hypothermia level we had
water cabins being thrown at us we fly
right in the middle of them we've even
had to reshoot some things as they turn
to blue and I can't accept on-screen
apparently I wanted her to be a strong
physical girl so I started to gain
muscle
strength she's just a real powerhouse
she made me embarrassed to take my shirt
off and I go to the gym five days a week
it's been a very physical adventure
Felicia has impressed me a lot the first
time we've seen her lead an action movie
this bull by the horns I love passion
for adventure he gets hit but she stands
up again
gonna have big sets and the mystical
doors being open always wanted to try
all these
action beats I feel like I have the
strength to do it
you
you